mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir je suis très heureux de vous
présenter pour la première fois ce soir
le nouveau jeu d armand jammot des
chiffres et des lettres comme tel
constat c'est ce jeu est très simple et
je débarque dans l'oeil et trop
longtemps avec des explications un peu
fastidieuse en fait qu'il reprend le
principe du mot le plus long que
beaucoup d'entre vous connaissent et ils
retrouveront j'espère avec plaisir mais
leur cette émission armand jammot
associé au mot plo à nouveau jeu de
chiffres
nous appellerons le compte est bon et
qui va vous permettre de faire les
opérations de calcul menthe
d'ailleurs je vais pas vous donner de
plus longues explications vous allez
découvrir ce jeu en jouant avec nous et
avec surtout avec le candidat
comedia qu'ils ont fait le plaisir de
bien vouloir inaugurait ce jeu et qui
est bien entendu maintenant on
connaissent parfaitement les règles je
vous présente d'abord à ma droite madame
coux bonsoir madame coxeurs donnez nous
quelques petits renseignements sur vous
pour la première fois que vous êtes
marié qui s'appelle comment alexandra je
pense qu'elle ne l'a pas encore
comprendre que nous sommes en train de
faire du camp star qui lui restait
pendant dix semaines peut-être que le
nom alto et de l'autre côté
monsieur pension bonjour monsieur
bonjour on vous êtes mario si marié oui
quel est votre profession représentant
représenter est-ce que ça vous dites pro
disposal aux lettres ou au calcul est
plutôt beaucoup plus aux calculs quand
même bien il va le voir si vos
prédictions se réalisent sous précise
enfin pour mémoire que le mot le plus
long aussi cette façon ce procès de la
façon suivante c'est à dire je vais
tirer cette lettre voyelles et consonnes
que vont l'être comme on dit qu'elle est
candidat et avec ces lettres ils devront
fabriquer le mot le plus long possible
mais ici intervient à notre ami max
favalelli qui a le redoutable honneur de
contrôler la valeur et l'orthographe des
mots qui lui sont proposés maxwell y va
d'ailleurs lui même
quels sont les mots qui sont acceptés ou
les mots qui sont refusés alors voici
notre code sont admis à tous les genres
masculin féminin singulier au pluriel
tous les mots simples composé figurant
dans un dictionnaire scolaire d'usagé
courant dans son édition la plus récente
ainsi que les verbe à l'infinitif elle
est parti passer accordé alors que vous
sont refusés les moines une lettre les
interjections des onomatopées pur les
préfixes des abréviations les sigles des
symboles chimique des locutions latines
l'élocution étrangère même usuelles dans
le langage courant et enfin les noms
propres de lieux ou de personnages
merci max ovalie nous sommes donc tout à
fait au courant je crois de façon dont
s'est déroulé le je suis d'accord mais
je pense aux jeunes pousses
il ne reste plus qu à petit la hausse
mais je pense que je peux me permettre
de demander à mme labrousse de choisir
la première phase et bien c'est pile et
c'est monsieur pension qui va commencer
tout de suite à jouer avec nous au mot
le plus long c'est pression je vous
écoute consonnes